how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
Marvel and everything relating to the
MCU now you may have caught the last
video I did about the marvel's Eternals
trailer coming very soon possibly at
Marvel's own Comic Con event the
Marvel's eternals teaser trailer has
been completed for some time now so no
doubt if there was an actual San Diego
comic-con this year Marvel Studios would
definitely be showing it however due to
cover 19 San Diego comic-con has kind of
been canceled they're doing it all at
home now online and since Saturday it
has been officially confirmed Marvel
Studios will not be attending San Diego
comic-con
at home but the last thing I said in my
last video was there is a chance that
Marvel Studios could be doing their own
event in which we could get the Eternals
trailer for it then however there is now
a possibility that it could come sooner
than that and I'll break down when and
where we could possibly expect the
Marvel's eternals trailer to pop up
sometime soon within the next two weeks
but first big congratulations to you too
but user baracus for being the winner of
my Thanos Infiniti gauntlet and Funko
pop giveaway email me in the email my
description and we'll get you your Funko
pop and for this week's Funko pop
giveaway we're going to be giving away a
Doctor Doom Funko pop so all you have to
do to enter is subscribe to my channel
like this video and leave a comment down
below about the video so again if you
didn't catch my last video about the
Eternals trailer over the weekend there
was a report that said Marvel Studios
has something planned in regards to the
Eternals it wasn't specified whether it
was just footage or an actual trailer
but the report said something is
supposed to be released soon and over
the weekend the community has begun to
speculate and it seems like we may have
figured out when exactly we're going to
get this trailer and that is most likely
when the NVA starts up in two weeks and
if that sounds a little weird
I'll explain to you why it actually
makes perfect sense Disney and Marvel
have been known to release major
trailers in sporting events if you
recall we got the Captain Marvel trailer
during a football game we recently got
the teaser trailers for the one division
series the Loki series and the Falcon
and the Winter Soldier teaser during the
Superbowl and in the past they have used
other big NFL games and in
be a games as well to release certain
trailers because let's not forget that
Disney has ABC and ESPN networks so one
thing they like to do is leverage these
trailers to bring in ratings for the
games and in about two weeks the NBA is
going to be starting back up again after
being closed for a pretty long time and
this is where many people are
speculating that we could receive the
Eternals trailer along with some footage
maybe for Falcon and the Winter Soldier
and the one division series and let's
not forget that Marvel and Disney are
already going to be showing the black
widow full movie to the NBA players so
Marvel has already worked out a deal
with the NBA to let them see Black Widow
they could certainly work out another
deal with their very own and networks to
show these new trailers and it just
makes sense for Marvel and Disney to do
this as well because there's going to be
so much hype in regards to the return of
the NBA pretty much all the major sports
league seasons have come to a halt due
to kovin 19 and a lot of Marvel Studios
has faced four projects had to be
shifted around as well as their
production Studios closing as well so
this would be a perfect way to not only
build a hype for the NBA restarting
again but to also build hype for movies
eventually starting again as well
because fans are definitely excited for
sports to start again but fans are
definitely excited for movies to start
again specifically the Marvel movies so
by releasing the trailers with the start
of the new sporting events there could
be just a ton of hype and Disney and
Marvel Studios both know this so there
is a chance that they could do what
they've done many times in the past and
attach trailers to certain big games
this means that the Eternals trailer
could come in as little as two weeks and
this would be the first official thing
or at least by Disney and Marvel Studios
in a very very long time now but it
wouldn't be a surprise if we saw the
Eternals trailer drop during a game and
we saw some more footage for Falcon in
the Winter Soldier and the wand of
vision series maybe even the Loki series
and Hawkeye series as well so things
could be getting very exciting in the
next couple of weeks if I hear anything
else don't worry I'll be sure to update
everybody with a video but in the
meantime let me know what you think
about this how excited are you for
Marvel Studios to finally be putting out
trailers again and which trailer are you
looking forward to the most to see be
sure to let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below don't forget to
this video and subscribe to stay up to
date on everything relating to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe for a live
updates you can follow me on Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching Wolf Wolf